" C’est sans doute
la première fois
que la représentation nationale
reçoit officiellement
et collectivement des acquittés
dans une affaire judiciaire. "
L’Affaire d’Outreau,
c’est un évènement judiciaire
en raison du fiasco judiciaire
qui a suivi cette affaire
qui a duré quand même
pendant 4 ans, de 2001 à 2005.
Dans ma tête,
j’avais imaginé
que si nous pouvions
diffuser cette commission
ça allait être une sorte
de feuilleton quotidien
pendant au moins 3-4 mois
et ça a été le cas !
" L’Assemblée nationale se devait
de vous exprimer son émotion
face au drame
que vous avez vécu
mais il nous incombe aussi
d’en tirer des leçons
pour éviter qu’un tel désastre
ne se reproduise. "
Et donc, de manière
un peu culottée,
je suis allé trouver
le Président Debré.
C’est un ancien juge d’instruction,
je lui ai dit :
écoutez, il faut que
cette commission soit publique,
soit transparente
parce que les Français attendent
des explications sur ce fiasco judiciaire.
" Qu’est-ce qu’il me reste maintenant ?
Un boulot de salarié...
et trois enfants.
Trois enfants détruits… "
La commission d’enquête a commencé,
je crois, le 10 janvier 2006
et s’est terminée
le 12 avril 2006.
" - Monsieur Fabrice Burgaud,
je vais donc vous demander maintenant
de lever la main droite
et de dire je le jure.
- Je le jure.
- Je vous remercie. "
Au bout d’une semaine,
tous les journalistes,
toutes les chaînes sont
au 101 rue de l’Université.
Nous, on a allumé
la mèche quelque part.
Le résultat des courses,
c’est une audience
qui est montée
je ne sais plus, mais
On est devenu une grande
chaîne publique à ce moment là.
Les 30 députés qui composaient
cette commission d’enquête
ont entendu plus
de 220 personnes.
Ils se sont permis
de bousculer les experts judiciaires
les psychiatres
et les psychologues.
Et ça, je dirais que c’était
une initiative politique noble.
" Vous êtes procureur
de la République.
Vous êtes garant
des libertés,
vous avez un rôle
très important ! "
C’était une première, parce que
pour une petite équipe comme LCP
elle affrontait
un événement politique considérable.
Cette commission d’enquête
a marqué l’histoire parlementaire et judiciaire.
Et LCP est au milieu
de cette affaire
et c’est ça
qui est fantastique.